[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dev ma Maison IL et un Pain
terrible dans la grosse branche pourrait
bien tomber
Sur mon pauvre toit quelle Belle
[Musique]
cible cette
branche Je vais la
couper aujourd'hui
[Musique]
peut-on ce sacré
Soleil me donne la
flemme Je la
cerai
après
demain et si je peux pas la couper
moi-même
[Musique]
ce n'est pas qu'on soit feignant par
ici mais IL fait si
chaud dans notre
midi
j'ai de beau lapins des lapins
superbes mais ils ont toujours envie de
manger IL faut tout le temps leur couper
de
l'herbe et je devrais
biener aujourd'hui
[Musique]
peut-il
demain ce sacré
Soleil me donne la flemme
j'en
ramser après demain et si je peux
pas en couper moi-meme
[Musique]
ce n'est pas qu'on soit feignant par
ici mais la terre est basse dans notre
midi la nuit du mois tu sais avec Thérèse
quand s'est trouvé tout
déshabille en sentant frémir son beau
corps de braise Je Me suis
Je pensais que je vais l'embraser
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
peut-on alors demain Moi les émotion
boul me rend tout
bl Hé
demanderai l'am ton et qui pourra très
et bien l'embraser
[Musique]
lui-meme
nos sommes
rois dans notre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m